hey youtubers is Charlie happy Black
Friday hopefully you guys haven't spent
all of your money but there is a Batman
V Superman teaser trailer that's coming
on Monday during Gotham so I'm gonna
play the promo clip that they aired for
and then talk about a couple other big
rumors inside the DC TV universe it is
the hardest question on the planet
Batman vs Superman I'm gonna have to go
with Batman I mean I won Gotham after
all
Batman vs Superman you know de vivre
Mizzou's our little Bruce Wayne is just
such a ferocious character I feel like
if I don't say Batman that he might beat
me up Patton versus Syria I'm gonna have
to go with Batman Superman is Superman
Superman's awesome you know Duke to do
but Batman's Batman is Batman the whole
way every day of the week
Batman obviously buddy Superman he's got
superpowers x-ray vision hello seriously
is that gonna get me fired catch an
exclusive sneak a Batman versus Superman
in Gotham this Monday on Fox I like the
fact that butch is one of the only
people who's like yeah I think Superman
Superman would totally win I'm not gonna
get fired am I I think it's a real shame
they didn't put the actor that plays
Bruce Wayne in that like they could have
just had him look at the camera and
stare like just glare into the lens with
his best Batman gaze what I'm expecting
from this Batman V Superman teaser
trailer is just a smaller version of
what we got with Captain America Civil
War that was actually a pretty big trial
I was really surprised when Jimmy Kimmel
posted that it sounds like there's gonna
be quite a bit of new footage in it so
I'm actually pretty pumped but for those
of you that are asking me about the
Supergirl flash crossover rumors and
Constantine legends of tomorrow stuff
there's actually like a whole bunch of
stuff going on to the DC Universe right
now but mostly the TV universe obviously
we have Batman V Superman stuff coming
up too but the deal with Supergirl first
cuz I feel like that's a bigger deal
because they said before Supergirl
season one there the CBS executives were
kind of like we kind of want to keep her
to ourselves but the rumor is is because
Supergirl is only currently picked up
for the 13 episode run there's like an
option for the back nine episodes it's
the way most television shows work
they'll pick it up for like a certain
block of episodes then if it's really
successful they'll give it a bunch of
extra episodes so the rumor goes because
they want to try and juice Supergirl
ratings as much as possible they want to
do like a big crazy event and that would
be a crossover with the flash so that
that's why they're open to it they want
to do something really big in the spring
warner brothers is also gonna have
Batman vs Superman dropping so it just
makes sense that they would try to do
some big DC crossover event the funny
thing about that of course is that they
already have legends of tomorrow coming
which is kind of like their big 13
episode crossover event so I think
because that exists is because it's
being hyped so much everyone is just
getting more on board with big TV
crossover
so until they explained how this
crossover would work I'm gonna stick to
what I said earlier and say Supergirl is
just on a different earth from where the
flash and arrow are right now we will
call her earth 3 although technically in
the DC universe earth 3 is the crime
syndicate earth and they're kind of
doing that with earth 2 on the flash
season 2 right now all things are
possible in the multiverse you can
actually think of the movies is
happening on a different earth inside
the multiverse but I am pretty excited I
know a lot of you guys asked me about
Supergirl I just I don't do a lot of
Supergirl videos because it overlaps
with a lot of other videos during a very
busy part of the week but it is a fun
show and the tone is very similar to the
flash so of course it makes sense that
she would crossover with the flash but
if it does happen I totally think that
they will have her do a footrace with
the flash I mean how could you not do
that but the other big news is
Constantine is rumored to be going on
legend to tomorrow season 2 this is kind
of premature too just because they
haven't even finished shooting legends
of tomorrow season 1 the reason why he
wouldn't go on legends of tomorrow
season 1 is because they've pretty much
finished riding all the episodes so to
try and work him in at this point would
be almost impossible from a scheduling
perspective they haven't picked up
legends of tomorrow for season 2 yet so
there's a lot of things that have to
happen before they can get Constantine
on the series but it's totally doable in
matt ryan is totally down to come back
for anything they want to use them for
really it's just a matter of scheduling
and finding the right story for him to
come back for like if they brought him
back it would have to be for some big
mystical storyline Vandal Savage kind of
does get into that but I would totally
like to see them get into some of the
demonology of the DC Universe if you're
gonna do that you might as well do it on
your big crazy action series but just to
be clear all these rumors about
Supergirl and Constantine they're all
very plausible like they're totally
doable it's just a matter of the network
saying okay yeah let's do this the thing
that does give me a lot of hope for all
this is the fact that Warner Brothers is
choosing to promote their biggest film
that's coming up on another network if
it wasn't clear though Bruno Heller the
the showrunner for Gotham has a deal at
Warner Brothers he'd developed Gotham
for Warner Brothers television they
produced the show
it's just that they sold it to Fox Bruno
Heller has a similar deal at Warner
Brothers television as Greg Berlanti
does like they both develop a bunch of
TV shows for Warner Brothers it's just
not all the shows air on networks that
Warner Brothers owns so they can do that
then they can tone
make a deal with CBS work and then they
can actually go to Gotham and say hey
look we were able to do this big
Supergirl CBS crossover with the flash
why don't we try this with Gotham now so
that proves anything to you guys it just
shows that networks will try anything if
they think that it will make their shows
more successful so what's gonna happen
on Monday because that Batman V Superman
video I'll do that first on Monday night
then I'll do my Gotham mid-season finale
video so be sure to subscribe to get
that I'll actually I'll have to do some
sort of Batman themed giveaway I always
do the reverse flash ring giveaway it's
during like flash arrow Supergirl videos
so now I have to like tie something in
with Gotham and Batman
so why goes wait for my next video to
post I'm still finishing Jessica Jones
you guys can click here for the Star
Wars trailer that I posted yesterday and
you can click here for the Captain
America civil war trailer from earlier
this week thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you